There's an old saying that a lawyer who represents himself has a fool for a client. And not many lawyers actually try it, but people like you and me apparently do, lots of us non-lawyers. The number's actually kind of shocking. In New York State alone, 1.8 million people represent themselves in court in a typical year. It's nine out of ten litigants in Housing Court, three out of four litigants in Family Court. So many amateurs gumming up the system that, years ago, the State decided to open up help centers, 23 of them all over the state, like this one in a courthouse in downtown Manhattan.
有句老话常说，自己担任自己律师的人，其客户是个傻瓜。没几个律师真的会这么做，但像你我这样的人似乎会，我们这些非律师人士中有不少人这样做。这个数字其实相当惊人。单在纽约州，平均每年就有180万人选择在法庭上为自己辩护。在房屋法庭，每十个诉讼当事人中就有九个是这样；在家庭法庭，每四个中就有三个是这样。这么多门外汉把司法系统搅得乱七八糟，以至于几年前，州政府决定开设援助中心，全州共有23个，就像曼哈顿市中心这家法院里的援助中心一样。
That's one of the three law school interns who are here giving advice today. And if you heard him say that and you thought to yourself, I don't know what summary judgment means either, I just want to say to you me too. Which is kind of the point. These are amateurs being sent in to do something that is technical, and full of jargon, and totally intimidating.
那是今天在这里提供建议的三名法学院实习生之一。如果你听到他刚才说的话，心里想“我也不知道什么是简易判决”，我想对你说，我也是。这正是问题的关键。这些门外汉被派去处理一些技术性强、充满专业术语且令人望而生畏的事情。
In criminal cases, you can get a free court-appointed attorney, but any other kind of case, housing, family law, credit issues, small claims, bankruptcy, civil cases of all kinds, you are on your own. And the reason that most people represent themselves is they just can't afford an attorney. So the number's been increasing as the economy's gotten worse.
在刑事案件中，你可以获得免费的法院指定律师，但在任何其他类型的案件中——住房、家庭法、信贷问题、小额索赔、破产、各类民事案件——你都必须靠自己。大多数人选择自我辩护的原因是他们实在请不起律师。随着经济形势恶化，这类人数一直在增加。
At this particular help center, which specializes in housing court cases, people wait in long lines and a big government room with green linoleum floors. One guy is so confused that he thinks that he's here to get a free lawyer to take his case. He fills out a form and then he takes it to the receptionist.
在这个专门处理房屋法庭案件的援助中心，人们在铺着绿色油毡地板的大型政府办公室内排长队等待。其中一个人非常困惑，他以为自己来到这里是为了请一位免费律师来代理他的案子。他填好一张表格，然后把它交给了接待员。
One of the attending court attorneys here, one named Ruth Sharfman, told one of our producers, Sean Cole, that, understandably, people have a lot of misconceptions about what is in the law.
这里的一位在场法院律师，名叫露丝·沙夫曼，告诉我们的制作人肖恩·科尔，可以理解，人们对法律的内容有很多误解。
I mean, some of them are almost-- well, they can't evict me, it's winter, you know? You don't throw people out New Year's Eve, but yeah, they can't evict me, I have a baby. It's like, watch them. They have to give me six months' more time to move out. No. They don't have to.
我是说，其中一些几乎是……好吧，他们不能驱逐我，现在是冬天，你知道吗？你不能在除夕夜把人赶出去，但是是的，他们不能驱逐我，我有个孩子。这就像是，走着瞧吧。他们必须给我六个月的时间搬出去。不，他们没必要这么做。
And then there are the people who come in terrified because they get a notice and think the Marshall's going to throw them out that afternoon. They don't realize they can't do it. They have to take you to court. You know, but they come in thinking well, don't I have the right to a lawyer? And the answer is yeah, you have the right to a lawyer. What you don't have is the right to one you don't pay for.
还有些人惊恐地走进来，因为他们收到了通知，认为法警当天下午就要把他们赶出去。他们没有意识到法警不能这样做。他们必须把你告上法庭。你知道，但他们进来时心想，难道我没有权利请律师吗？答案是，是的，你有权请律师。但你没有权利请一位不用付费的律师。
As you might expect, some lawyers and judges hate these amateur lawyers. Imagine being a surgeon and having somebody in the operating room in a key position who doesn't know the names of the instruments or what they can do. The legal term for representing yourself in court is a Latin phrase, pro se, which means on behalf of himself.
正如你所预料的那样，一些律师和法官痛恨这些业余律师。想象一下，你是一名外科医生，手术室里的关键岗位上有一个人，他连手术器械的名称或用途都不知道。在法庭上为自己辩护的法律术语是一个拉丁短语，pro se，意为“代表自己”。
And so today, on our radio show, we have four very dramatic stories of pro se people, people brave enough-- or desperate enough, actually, in most of these cases-- to become their own advocates. One of them does that in a courtroom, the others do it out in the world.
所以今天，在我们的广播节目中，我们有四个关于“代表自己”人士的非常戏剧性的故事，这些人足够勇敢——或者说，在大多数情况下是足够绝望——去成为自己的辩护人。其中一人在法庭上这样做，其他人则在现实生活中这样做。
From WBEZ, Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Act 1 of our show today, Psycho Dabble. Jon Ronson has the tale of a teenager who simply has to outwit professional psychiatrists, and a lot of them.
来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际分发。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天节目的第一幕，“心理浅谈”。乔恩·荣森讲述了一个不得不智斗专业精神病学家的少年的故事，而且是智斗许多个精神病学家。
Act 2, Disorder in the Court, in which I talk to a prosecutor who has lost to an amateur who was defending himself.
第二幕，“法庭混乱”，我与一位曾输给自我辩护的业余人士的检察官交谈。
Act 3, Swak Down, in that act a brother does what he has to to help his sister.
第三幕，“吻我”，在这一幕中，一个兄弟为了帮助他的妹妹做了他必须做的事。
Act 4, Underling Gets An Underling. Stay with us.
第四幕，“下属有了下属”。请继续收听。
Act 1, Psycho Dabble. Jon Ronson, in London, has this story of a guy named Tony who has spent years representing himself trying to prove a case with some people who think he's crazy. Literally.
第一幕，“心理浅谈”。身在伦敦的乔恩·荣森带来了关于托尼的故事，他多年来一直自我辩护，试图与一些认为他疯了的人打官司。字面意义上的疯了。
I first heard of Tony three months ago when I was having lunch with a Scientologist called Brian Daniels. Brian runs the British office of an international network of Scientologists called the Citizens Commission on Human Rights. They're determined to prove to the world that psychiatrists are wicked and must be stopped.
我三个月前第一次听说托尼，当时我正与一位名叫布莱恩·丹尼尔斯的科学教派成员共进午餐。布莱恩负责一个名为“公民人权委员会”的国际科学教派网络的英国分部。他们决心向世界证明精神病学家是邪恶的，必须被阻止。
Brian and I shared a mistrust of psychiatry. Admittedly, his loathing was deep and abiding and I'd only had mine for a few days, but it gave us something to talk about over lunch. When dessert came, he put down his spoon and he said, "You should meet Tony." "Who's Tony?" I asked. "Tony's in Broadmoor." said Brian.
布莱恩和我对精神病学有着共同的不信任。诚然，他对精神病学的厌恶是深沉而持久的，而我的厌恶才持续了几天，但这让我们在午餐时有了交谈的话题。当上甜点时，他放下勺子说：“你应该见见托尼。”“托尼是谁？”我问。“托尼在布罗德莫，”布莱恩说。
I put down my spoon. Broadmoor is Broadmoor Psychiatric Hospital. It was once known as Broadmoor Asylum for the Criminally Insane. This is where they sent Ian Brady, the "Moors Murderer," who killed five children in Manchester in the 1960s. And Peter Sutcliffe, the Yorkshire Ripper, who murdered 13 women in the 1970s. And the Stockwell Strangler, who murdered seven elderly people in 1986. Broadmoor is where they sentence the serial killers, and the pedophiles, and the child murderers, the ones who couldn't help themselves.
我放下勺子。布罗德莫是布罗德莫精神病院。它曾经被称为布罗德莫刑事精神病患者收容所。这里曾关押过伊恩·布雷迪，即20世纪60年代在曼彻斯特杀害五名儿童的“沼泽杀手”；以及20世纪70年代谋杀13名女性的“约克郡开膛手”彼得·萨特克利夫；还有1986年谋杀七名老人的“斯托克韦尔扼杀者”。布罗德莫是判处连环杀手、恋童癖者和儿童谋杀犯的地方，那些无法控制自己的人。
"What did Tony do?" I asked Brian. "Tony," said Brian, "is completely sane. He faked his way in there, and now he's stuck. Nobody will believe he's sane." "What do you mean?" I asked. "He was arrested years ago for something." said Brian. "I think he beat someone up or something, and he decided to fake madness to get out of a prison sentence. So they sent him to Broadmoor, and now he's stuck. The more he tries to convince the psychiatrists he's not crazy, the more they take it as evidence that he is. Do you want me to get you into Broadmoor to meet Tony?"
“托尼做了什么？”我问布莱恩。“托尼，”布莱恩说，“完全神志清醒。他伪装成精神病混了进去，现在被困住了。没人相信他是清醒的。”“什么意思？”我问。“他几年前因为某事被捕了，”布莱恩说。“我想他殴打了一个人还是别的什么，他决定伪装成疯子以逃避监禁。所以他们把他送到了布罗德莫，现在他被困住了。他越是试图说服精神病学家他没有疯，他们就越把它视为他是疯子的证据。你想让我带你去布罗德莫见托尼吗？”
I automatically started thinking about what I'd do if I had to prove I was sane. I'd like to think that just being my regular, sane self would be evidence enough. But I'd probably behave in such an overly polite, and helpful, and competent manner, I'd come across like a mad butler with panic in his eyes. Plus it turns out that when I'm placed in an insane situation, I tend to get crazier.
我自动开始思考，如果我必须证明自己是清醒的，我会怎么做。我愿意认为，仅仅表现出我正常、清醒的一面就足以证明了。但我可能会表现得过于礼貌、乐于助人且能干，看起来就像一个眼中带着惊恐的疯狂管家。而且事实证明，当我处于疯狂的环境中时，我往往会变得更疯狂。
Recently, I was mid-air on a plane with no leg room. And it was so packed and claustrophobic, I let out a loud, involuntary yelp. I shouted, "Eww!" I didn't know that such mysterious, crazy noises existed within me.
最近，我在飞机上，腿部空间很窄。飞机里太拥挤，让我感到幽闭恐惧，我发出了一声响亮的、不由自主的尖叫。我大喊：“呃！”我不知道我体内竟然存在着如此神秘、疯狂的声音。
Did I want to meet Tony? I looked at Brian. "OK." I said.
我想见托尼吗？我看了看布莱恩。“好吧，”我说。
My mistrust of psychiatrists began the previous Monday when I was at a friend's house and I happened to notice on her shelf a book called, DSM-IV-TR . I've been told that many Americans have heard of this book, but it was new to me. My friend explained that it was the psychiatrist's manual published by the American Psychiatric Association.
我对精神病学家的不信任始于上周一，当时我在一位朋友家，偶然注意到她书架上有一本名为《精神疾病诊断与统计手册第四版修订版》（DSM-IV-TR）的书。我被告知许多美国人都听说过这本书，但对我来说是全新的。我的朋友解释说，这是美国精神医学学会出版的精神科医生手册。
It was huge, some 900 pages. And I later found out that it sits on the shelves of psychiatry offices all over the world and it lists every known mental disorder. While flipping through it, I instantly diagnosed myself with 12 different disorders including, but not limited to: Disorder of Written Expression, which is poor handwriting; Arithmetic Learning Disorder, which has luckily been cured since I bought a calculator; and Nightmare Disorder, which is diagnosed when the sufferer dreams of being pursued or declared a failure. All my nightmares involve someone chasing me down the street whilst yelling, "You're a failure!"
这本书非常厚，大约900页。后来我发现，它就放在世界各地精神科医生办公室的书架上，列出了所有已知的精神障碍。翻阅时，我立刻给自己诊断出了12种不同的障碍，包括但不限于：书写表达障碍，即字迹潦草；算术学习障碍，幸运的是，自从我买了计算器后就治愈了；还有噩梦障碍，当患者梦见自己被追赶或被判定为失败者时会被诊断为此病。我所有的噩梦都涉及有人在大街上追赶我，同时大喊：“你是个失败者！”
I closed the manual. I never realized how unbelievably nuts I was. Or maybe I wasn't nuts at all. Maybe the American Psychiatric Association were the nutty ones. I wanted to find a critic of psychiatry, someone who'd studied its irrationalities, so I could test this new theory. So I did a Google search and found Brian and the CCHR. And that's how, two Saturdays later, I ended up in a car with Brian heading towards Broadmoor in Crowthorne, a village to the west of London.
我合上手册。我从来没有意识到我竟然如此疯狂。或者也许我根本就没疯。也许美国精神医学学会的那些人才是疯子。我想找一位精神病学的批评家，一个研究过其非理性的人，这样我就可以测试这个新理论。于是我用谷歌搜索，找到了布莱恩和公民人权委员会（CCHR）。这就是为什么两周后的那个周六，我最终坐在布莱恩的车里，前往位于伦敦西部克罗索恩村的布罗德莫。
Although Brian's group had been quietly helping Tony with his various legal tribunals to try and get him out of Broadmoor, they hadn't yet introduced him to a journalist. I was to be the first. The visitor's center, housed behind high security fence, after fence, after fence, was painted in the calming hues of a letter complex: peaches, and pinks, and pine. The prints on the wall were pastel paintings of French doors opening onto beaches at sunrise. The building was called The Wellness Center.
虽然布莱恩的组织一直在悄悄地帮助托尼处理各种法律法庭程序以试图让他离开布罗德莫，但他们还没有把他介绍给记者。我将是第一个。访客中心坐落在层层高大的安全围栏后面，被漆成一种令人平静的复合色调：桃色、粉色和松木色。墙上的版画是法式门通向日出海滩的柔和色调画作。这座建筑被称为“健康中心”。
Brian said the attorney would be a minute because it's a bit of a walk from the Dangerous and Severe Personality Disorder unit. I looked at Brian. "Is Tony in the part of Broadmoor that houses the most dangerous people?" I asked. "Crazy, isn't it?" laughed Brian.
布莱恩说律师要等一会儿才能过来，因为从“危险和严重人格障碍”部门走过来有一段距离。我看着布莱恩。“托尼住在布罗德莫关押最危险罪犯的区域吗？”我问。“很疯狂，不是吗？”布莱恩笑着说。
Patients began drifting in to sit with their loved ones at tables and chairs that had been nailed to the ground. They all looked quite similar to each other: quite docile and sad-eyed, overweight, and wearing loose T-shirts and sweat pants. I suppose there's not much to do in here but eat. They drank tea and ate chocolate bars from the dispenser with their parents. I wondered if any of them were famous.
病人们开始晃晃悠悠地走进来，与他们的亲人在被钉在地板上的桌椅旁坐下。他们看起来彼此非常相似：相当温顺，眼神忧郁，超重，穿着宽松的T恤和运动裤。我想除了吃东西，这里也没什么可做的。他们喝着茶，和父母一起吃着自动售货机买的巧克力棒。我好奇他们中是否有人很有名。
"Oh, here's Tony now." said Brian. I looked across the room. A man, who looked to be in his late 20s, was walking towards us. He wasn't shuffling like the others had, he was sauntering. His arm was outstretched. He wasn't wearing sweat pants, he was wearing a pinstriped jacket and trousers. He looked like a young businessman trying to make his way in the world, like someone on The Apprentice, a man who wants to show everyone that he was very, very sane.
“哦，托尼来了。”布莱恩说。我望向房间另一头。一个看起来二十出头的男人朝我们走来。他不像其他人那样拖着脚走路，而是悠闲地踱步。他的手臂伸展着。他没有穿运动裤，而是穿着条纹夹克和裤子。他看起来像一个正在努力在这个世界上打拼的年轻商人，就像《学徒》节目里的人，一个想要向所有人展示他非常、非常清醒的人。
And, of course, as I watched him approach our table, I wondered if the pinstripe was a clue that he was sane, or a clue that he wasn't. He shook my hand and sat down. "So Brian says you faked your way in here." I said. "That's exactly right." said Tony. He had the voice of a normal, nice, eager-to-help young man. "I'd committed GBH," he said, "grievous bodily harm. After they arrested me, I sat in my cell and I thought, I'm looking at five to seven years. So I asked the other prisoners what to do. They said, 'Easy. Tell them you're mad. They'll put you in a county hospital. You'll have Sky TV and a PlayStation. Nurses will bring you pizzas.' "But they didn't send me to some cushy hospital. They sent me to bloody Broadmoor." "How long ago was this?" I asked. "12 years ago." said Tony. I involuntarily grinned. Tony grinned back.
当然，当我看着他走向我们的桌子时，我想知道这身条纹西装是他清醒的线索，还是他不清醒的线索。他和我握了握手，坐了下来。“所以布莱恩说你伪装成疯子才进来的。”我说。“完全正确。”托尼说。他的声音听起来像一个正常、友好、急于提供帮助的年轻人。“我犯了严重身体伤害罪（GBH），”他说，“在他们逮捕我之后，我坐在牢房里想，我可能会被判五到七年。所以我问其他囚犯该怎么办。他们说，‘简单，告诉他们你疯了。他们会把你送到县医院。你有天空卫视和PlayStation可以玩。护士会给你送披萨。’但他们并没有把我送到那种舒服的医院，他们把我送到了该死的布罗德莫。”“这是多久以前的事了？”我问。“12年前。”托尼说。我不由自主地咧嘴笑了。托尼也回以微笑。
I wasn't allowed to tape Tony, which is why you're not hearing his voice. But I've had several long conversations with him now, in person and over the phone. I didn't want this story to cause him any more trouble with the authorities, so I decided to change Tony's name. I asked him to choose a name, and we decided on Tony.
我不被允许录下托尼的声音，这就是为什么你听不到他的录音。但我现在已经和他进行过几次长时间的交谈，无论是当面还是通过电话。我不希望这个故事给他与当局的关系带来更多麻烦，所以我决定更改托尼的名字。我让他选择一个名字，我们决定叫他托尼。
Tony said faking madness to get in was the easy part, especially when you're 17, and you take drugs, and you watch a lot of scary movies. You don't need to know how authentically crazy people behave, you just plagiarize the character that Dennis Hopper played in the movie Blue Velvet.
托尼说伪装疯狂进去是最简单的部分，特别是当你17岁，吸食毒品，并且看了很多恐怖电影的时候。你不需要知道真正疯狂的人是如何表现的，你只需要剽窃丹尼斯·霍珀在电影《蓝丝绒》中扮演的角色。
That's what Tony did. He told a visiting psychiatrist that he liked sending people love letters straight from his heart, and a love letter is a bullet from a gun. And if you receive a love letter from him, you'll go straight to Hell.
这就是托尼所做的。他告诉一位来访的精神病学家，他喜欢从内心深处给别人写情书，而情书就是枪里的子弹。如果你收到他的情书，你就会直接下地狱。
As more psychiatrists began visiting Tony's cell, he broadened his repertoire to include bits from Hellraiser, A Clockwork Orange , and the David Cronenberg movie Crash , in which people get sexual pleasure from enacting car crashes. He even told one psychiatrist that he wanted to kill women because he thought looking into their eyes as they died would make him feel normal, a tidbit he got from the book about the serial killer, Ted Bundy, that he found in the prison library.
随着越来越多的精神病学家开始探访托尼的牢房，他扩大了他的剧目，加入了电影《猛鬼追魂》、《发条橙》以及大卫·柯南伯格的电影《撞车》的片段，电影里人们通过模仿车祸获得性快感。他甚至告诉一位精神病学家，他想杀死女性，因为他认为看着她们死时的眼睛会让他感到正常，这是他从监狱图书馆里找到的一本关于连环杀手泰德·邦迪的书里学到的片段。
As Tony told me his story, Brian sat next to us chuckling, dryly, at the lunacy of psychiatrists. I didn't know what to think. Unlike the sad-eyed, medicated patients all around us, Tony did seem completely ordinary and sane.
当托尼告诉我他的故事时，布莱恩坐在我们旁边，干笑着精神病学家的疯狂。我不知道该想什么。与周围那些眼神忧郁、服用药物的病人们不同，托尼看起来确实完全普通且清醒。
"They took my word for everything." Tony said. Tony said that the day he arrived at Broadmoor, he took one look at the place and realized he'd make a spectacularly bad decision. He urgently asked to speak to the psychiatrists. "I am not mentally ill," he told them. Tony said that it's a lot harder to convince people you're sane than it is to convince them that you're crazy.
“他们对我说的一切照单全收。”托尼说。托尼说，他到达布罗德莫的那天，看了一眼那个地方，意识到自己做了一个极其错误的决定。他迫切要求与精神病学家交谈。“我没有精神病，”他告诉他们。托尼说，说服别人你清醒比说服别人你疯了要难得多。
He found that when you try and act sane in front of people who believe that you aren't, you get self-conscious. Your smile seems too wide. Psychiatrists like to scrutinize body movements, so he had to calculate how to walk like a sane person, even how to dress like one. He said that he was fully aware that when he decided to wear pinstripe to meet me, he was taking a risk. The look could go either way.
他发现，当你在那些认为你有病的人面前表现得清醒时，你会变得自负。你的笑容似乎太宽了。精神病学家喜欢审视身体动作，所以他必须计算如何像正常人一样走路，甚至如何像正常人一样穿衣。他说他完全意识到，当他决定穿条纹西装见我时，他在冒险。这种造型可能产生截然不同的效果。
"I thought the best way to seem normal," he said, "was to talk to people normally about normal things like football and what's on TV." So that's what he did at first, but in Broadmoor everything is open to interpretation.
“我觉得看起来正常的最好方法，”他说，“就是和人们谈论足球和电视节目之类的正常事情。”所以起初他就是这么做的，但在布罗德莫，一切都可以被解读。
One time, quite early on, he happened to tell a ward nurse, "Did you know that the US military is training bumble bees to sniff out explosives?" Tony had seen an article about this in New Scientist Magazine. Later, when he read his medical notes, he saw that someone had written, "thinks bees can sniff out explosives."
有一次，很早的时候，他偶然告诉一位病房护士：“你知道吗？美国军方正在训练大黄蜂来探测炸药。”托尼在《新科学家》杂志上看过关于这个的文章。后来，当他读到自己的医疗记录时，他看到有人写道：“认为蜜蜂可以探测炸药。”
At the time, Tony thought that being helpful and polite and volunteering to do things like weeding the hospital garden would be his ticket out of there. But the tactic failed. "They saw how well-behaved I was." he told me, "and they decided that I could only behave well in the environment of a psychiatric hospital. And this proved I was mad." I instinctively didn't believe Tony about this. It seemed too absurd. But later on, he sent me one of his psychiatric reports and, sure enough, it was right there. "Tony is cheerful and friendly," the report stated. "His detention in hospital is preventing deterioration of his condition." It even mentioned weeding the garden.
当时，托尼以为乐于助人、礼貌并且主动做像除草这样的事情会成为他离开那里的通行证。但这个策略失败了。“他们看到了我表现得有多好，”他告诉我，“然后他们认定，我只有在精神病院的环境下才能表现良好。这证明了我确实疯了。”我本能地不相信托尼说的这一点。这看起来太荒谬了。但后来，他给我寄来了他的一份精神病报告，果然，就在上面。报告写道：“托尼开朗友好。他在医院的拘留防止了他的病情恶化。”它甚至提到了除草这件事。
So, after a while, Tony stopped being well-behaved. In any case, he really wasn't fond of hanging around rapists, and pedophiles, and child murderers. It was unsavory and also quite frightening. "I've got the Stockwell Strangler on one side of me, and the Tiptoe Through the Tulips Rapist on the other." he said.
所以，过了一段时间，托尼不再表现得那么好了。不管怎样，他确实不喜欢和强奸犯、恋童癖者和儿童谋杀犯混在一起。那既令人作呕，也相当可怕。“我的一侧是‘斯托克韦尔扼杀者’，另一侧是‘郁金香舞者强奸犯’。”他说。
The Stockwell Strangler, his name is Kenneth Erskine. "Kenny's OK." said Tony. "He's-- well, I was about to say he's a harmless character but, clearly, he's not." Tony smiled. "One time I grabbed him from behind and put my arm around his neck, and I said, 'This makes a change, doesn't it, Kenny? You're not often on this side of the fence, are you mate?' Anyway, they didn't like that at all. They said I had no understanding that, that wasn't a funny joke."
“斯托克韦尔扼杀者”的名字是肯尼思·厄斯金。“肯尼还可以。”托尼说。“他……好吧，我本来想说他是个无害的角色，但显然，他不是。”托尼笑了。“有一次我从背后抓住他，用手臂搂住他的脖子，我说，‘这感觉换换样了吧，肯尼？你可不常在这边，对吧，伙计？’不管怎样，他们一点也不喜欢那样。他们说我根本不明白那不是一个好笑的笑话。”
Tony started withdrawing to his room a lot to avoid his criminally insane neighbors. He said on the outside this would be a perfectly understandable position, but on the inside, it demonstrates that you're withdrawn and aloof and you have a grandiose sense of your own importance. In Broadmoor, not wanting to hang out with pedophiles is a sign of madness.
托尼开始频繁躲在自己的房间里，以避开那些刑事精神失常的邻居。他说在外面这会是一个完全可以理解的姿态，但在里面，这表明你退缩、冷漠，并且有一种妄自尊大的感觉。在布罗德莫，不想和恋童癖者混在一起是疯狂的迹象。
Eventually Tony devised a radical scheme. He realized that if you engage with the therapy, it's an indication that you're getting better. And if you're getting better, they have a legal right to detain you. So Tony deduced that if he took no therapy at all, he couldn't get better. He'd be deemed officially untreatable so they'd have to let him go. The problem was that, at Broadmoor, if a nurse sits next to you at lunch and makes small talk, and you make small talk back, that's considered engaging with therapy. So Tony had to tell them all, will you sit at another table? And that's when they decided he was really going nuts.
最终，托尼设计了一个激进的计划。他意识到，如果你配合治疗，这表明你正在好转。如果你正在好转，他们就有合法的权利拘留你。所以托尼推断，如果他根本不接受治疗，他就不会好转。他会被正式认定为不可治愈，所以他们就不得不让他走。问题是，在布罗德莫，如果护士在午餐时坐在你旁边闲聊，而你也回话，那就被认为是在配合治疗。所以托尼不得不告诉他们所有人，你们能坐在另一张桌子旁吗？就在那时，他们认定他真的疯了。
The patient's behavior is getting worse at Broadmoor, said one report. He does not engage. And his tactical refusal to engage showed him to be cunning and manipulative. To top it off, he was suffering from cognitive distortion because he didn't believe he was mad.
一份报告称，病人在布罗德莫的行为正在恶化。他不配合。他这种策略性的拒绝配合表明他狡猾且具有操纵性。最糟糕的是，他患有认知扭曲，因为他不相信自己疯了。
Tony was funny for most of my two hours with him, but towards the end he got sadder. "I arrived here when I was 17." he said. "I'm 29 now. I've grown up in Broadmoor, wandering the wards of Broadmoor. This is supposed to be the best years of your life. I've seen suicides. I saw a man take another man's eye out." Tony said just being here can be enough to turn someone crazy.
托尼在我跟他待的两个小时里大部分时间都很风趣，但快结束时他变得忧郁。“我17岁时来到这里。”他说。“现在我29岁了。我在布罗德莫长大，在布罗德莫的病房里游荡。这本应是你一生中最好的时光。我见过自杀。我见过一个男人挖掉另一个男人的眼睛。”托尼说，仅仅待在这里就足以让一个人变疯。
Then one of the guards called out a word. It might have been time. And with barely a goodbye, Tony immediately shot from our table and across the room to the door that led back to his block. All the patients did the same. It was a display of tremendous, extreme, acute, good behavior.
然后一名警卫喊了一个词。可能是时间到了。几乎没有告别，托尼立刻从我们的桌子冲到房间对面，奔向通往他病区的门。所有的病人都做了同样的事情。这表现出了一种极其、极其、极其良好的纪律性。
Brian's organization, the CCHR, has a museum on Sunset Boulevard called Psychiatry: An Industry of Death. One of their spokespeople is the former Cheers star, Kirstie Alley. The DVD, which I watched when I got home, reveals a catalog of unbelievably horrible abuses perpetrated by psychiatrists throughout history.
布莱恩的组织，公民人权委员会（CCHR），在日落大道上有一个名为“精神病学：死亡产业”的博物馆。他们的发言人之一是前《欢乐酒店》明星柯斯蒂·艾利。我回家时观看的那张光盘，揭露了一份精神病学家在整个历史上犯下的令人难以置信的可怕虐待行为清单。
[BEGIN AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频回放开始]
-After slavery was abolished, psychiatric racism not only persisted, it intensified.
-奴隶制废除后，精神病学中的种族主义不仅持续存在，而且加剧了。
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频回放结束]
At the outset, it was very convincing. Here's the American physician, Samuel Cartright, identifying in 1851, a mental disorder, drapetomania, evident only in slaves. The sole symptom of this disorder was the desire to run away from slavery. The cure was whipping the devil out of them as a preventative measure.
起初，它非常令人信服。这是美国医生塞缪尔·卡特赖特，他在1851年确定了一种精神障碍，即“漫游狂”，仅在奴隶中表现明显。这种障碍的唯一症状是渴望逃离奴隶制。治愈方法是鞭打他们以作为预防措施。
Here is archive of the neurologist Walter Freeman hammering an ice pick through a patient's eye socket sometime during the 1950s. Freeman would travel America in his loboto-mobile, it's a sort of camper van, enthusiastically lobotomizing wherever he was allowed.
这是神经学家沃尔特·弗里曼在20世纪50年代某个时候用冰镐穿过患者眼窝的档案。弗里曼会开着他的“脑叶切除车”（一种露营车）在全美各地旅行，狂热地在任何被允许的地方进行脑叶切除手术。
[BEGIN AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频回放开始]
-Hacking apart his patient's brains on stage or sometimes right there in the vehicle.
-在舞台上或有时就在车里肢解病人的大脑。
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频回放结束]
Here's a psychiatrist actually electrocuting a kitten. Well, you see black and white footage of a kitten being electrocuted. And the inference is that the pair of hands responsible belongs to a psychiatrist. By this point in the DVD, I wouldn't put anything past those bastards.
这是一个精神病学家正在电击一只小猫。好吧，你看到了小猫被电击的黑白镜头。推论是，负责那双手的属于一位精神病学家。在这张光盘的这个阶段，我毫不怀疑那些混蛋会做出任何事情。
[BEGIN AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频回放开始]
-Psychiatrists commit one third of the sex-related offenses committed by doctors.
-精神病学家实施了医生所犯罪行中三分之一的性相关犯罪。
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[音频回放结束]
The DVD, eventually, spirals into a big, anti-psychiatry conspiracy theory. Psychiatry is responsible for 9/11, The Holocaust, Columbine, and its ultimate secret master plan is to enslave the world. The commentary says in every city, every state, every country, you will find psychiatrists committing rape, sexual abuse, murder and fraud.
这张光盘最终演变成了一个巨大的反精神病学阴谋论。精神病学应对9/11、大屠杀、科伦拜恩事件负责，其最终的秘密总体规划是奴役世界。评论说，在每个城市、每个州、每个国家，你都会发现精神病学家犯下强奸、性虐待、谋杀和欺诈行为。
A few days passed. Then a letter arrived from Tony. This place is awful at nighttime, John, he wrote. Words cannot express the atmosphere. I noticed that the wild daffodils were in bloom this morning. I felt like running through them, as I used to in my childhood with my mom. This is when I got to see Tony's files. It included them in the package. They confirmed all the crazy stories he'd told the psychiatrists back in '98 when he was trying to get out of a prison sentence. It also included a description of the crime he'd committed.
几天过去了。然后托尼寄来了一封信。约翰，这地方晚上的气氛太可怕了，他写道。语言无法表达那种氛围。我注意到野生水仙花今天早上开了。我想跑进花丛中，就像我童年时和妈妈在一起时那样。这时我才有机会看到托尼的档案。我把它们包含在了包裹里。它们证实了他98年试图逃避监禁时告诉精神病学家的所有疯狂故事。它还包括对他所犯罪行的描述。
The victim was a homeless man, an alcoholic, who happened to be passing. He apparently made an inappropriate comment about one of Tony's friends. Tony, who was drunk, and stoned, and 17, kicked him seven or eight times in the stomach and groin. He left him, walked back to his friends and had another drink. He then returned to the man, who still lying motionless on the floor, and he head butted him and kicked him again. He kicked him again, in the face, and walked away.
受害者是一名刚好路过的无家可归的酗酒者。他显然对托尼的一个朋友发表了不恰当的评论。托尼当时喝醉了，嗑了药，才17岁，他向受害者的腹部和腹股沟踢了七八脚。他离开了，走回朋友身边又喝了一杯。然后他回到那个人身边，那个人仍躺在地上动弹不得，他用头撞击那人，并再次踢他。他又踢了他的脸，然后走开了。
I felt the ground shift slightly under my feet. I remember that list of the movies Tony plagiarized to demonstrate that he was mentally ill. One was A Clockwork Orange , which begins with a gang of thugs kicking a homeless man while he was on the floor. My phone rang. I recognized the number. It was Tony. I didn't answer it.
我感到脚下的地面微微移动。我记得托尼为了证明自己精神失常而剽窃的那些电影列表。其中一部是《发条橙》，开头是一群暴徒在踢一个倒在地上的无家可归者。我的电话响了。我认出了那个号码。是托尼。我没有接。
A month passed. Then an email I'd been waiting for arrived. It was from Professor Anthony Maden, he's the head clinician at Tony's unit. Tony had given me his name. Anthony Maden wouldn't agree to go on tape, but he was happy to answer my questions in writing. Tony, the email read, did get here by faking mental illness because he thought it would be preferable to prison. I felt a huge surge of relief and warmer towards Tony again. But next line in the email wasn't so great. It said, most psychiatrists who've assessed him, and there have been a lot, have concluded that he is not mentally ill, but suffers from a psychopathic personality disorder.
一个月过去了。然后我一直等待的电子邮件到了。来自安东尼·马登教授，他是托尼病区的首席临床医生。托尼给了我他的名字。安东尼·马登不愿接受录音采访，但他乐意以书面形式回答我的问题。电子邮件写道，托尼确实是因为认为精神病院比监狱更可取，所以通过伪装精神病来到了这里。我感到一阵巨大的宽慰，再次对托尼感到温暖。但邮件的下一行就不那么好了。上面写着，大多数评估过他的精神病学家——他们有很多——得出的结论是，他并没有精神病，而是患有精神病性人格障碍。
I looked at the email. Tony's a psychopath, I thought. Tony rang again. I didn't answer. I emailed Professor Maden. Isn't that like that scene in the movie, Ghost , when Whoopi Goldberg pretends to be a psychic, and then it turns out that she actually can talk to the dead? No, he emailed back. It isn't like that Whoopi Goldberg scene at all. Tony faked mental illness. Mental illness can include symptoms like hallucinations and delusions. Mental illness comes and goes. It can get better with medication. Tony is a psychopath. That doesn't come and go. That is how the person is.
我看着这封邮件。托尼是个精神变态，我想。托尼又打来电话。我没有接。我给马登教授发了邮件。这不就像电影《人鬼情未了》里的那个场景吗，乌比·戈德堡假装自己是灵媒，结果发现她真的能和死者交谈？不，他回复说。这完全不像那个乌比·戈德堡的场景。托尼伪装了精神病。精神病可能包括幻觉和妄想等症状。精神病时有时无。它可以通过药物好转。托尼是精神变态。那不是时有时无的。这就是这个人的本质。
I wondered what the difference was between a psychopath and a sociopath. And the answer is, there isn't really one. The terms are, pretty much, used interchangeably. A psychopath is someone who doesn't have the part of the brain that provides conscience, and empathy, and remorse.
我好奇精神变态者和社会变态者之间有什么区别。答案是，并没有真正区别。这两个词几乎可以互换使用。精神变态者是指大脑中缺乏良知、同情心和悔意的那部分的人。
Professor Maden said faking mental illness to try to get a cushy hospital sentence is the, typically, deceitful act of a psychopath. Tony faking his brain going wrong was the act of someone whose brain had gone wrong. He wrote, of course, you can always argue, as with any mental disorder, that the very concept is invalid. But if one accepts that there is such an entity, Tony has it. He added that if Tony had just agreed to have treatment, he'd have been out years ago. But, he said, claiming you're untreatable in order to get out is typical of a psychopath.
马登教授说，伪装精神病以试图获得舒适的医院判决是精神变态者典型的欺诈行为。托尼伪装自己的大脑出了问题，是那种大脑确实出了问题的人的行为。他写道，当然，你可以像对待任何精神障碍一样辩称这个概念本身无效。但如果你接受这种实体的存在，托尼就患有此病。他补充说，如果托尼早点同意接受治疗，他几年前就出去了。但是，他说，为了逃避而声称自己不可治愈，是精神变态者的典型行为。
Tony swears he isn't a psychopath. He says he feels lots of remorse for what he did, but when he expresses remorse, psychiatrists claim it's part of a psychopath's make up to say they're remorseful when they're not. He says when he faked mental illness back in 1980, he must have stupidly included some fake psychopathic stuff in there too. He says trying to prove you're not a psychopath is even harder than trying to prove you're not mentally ill.
托尼发誓他不是精神变态。他说他对自己的所作所为感到非常后悔，但当他表达悔意时，精神病学家声称那是精神变态者伪装悔意的组成部分。他说，当他在1980年伪装精神病时，他一定愚蠢地把一些虚假的精神变态内容也混进去了。他说试图证明自己不是精神变态比试图证明自己没有精神病更难。
But I didn't feel quite so persuaded by Tony now. His story didn't seem like such a darkly absurd catch-22 situation anymore. I felt I persuaded by Professor Maden instead. And I think I would have continued feeling that way about Tony if I hadn't spoken to Professor Sashi Sashidharan.
但我现在并没有被托尼说服。他的故事看起来不再像那种黑暗荒诞的“第22条军规”式处境。我觉得我被马登教授说服了。如果我没有和萨希·萨什达兰教授交谈，我想我会继续那样看待托尼。
If you give me just a second, John, I will just look at what I wrote down at the time.
如果你能给我一秒钟，约翰，我查查我当时记下的内容。
Professor Sashidharan is an independent consultant psychiatrist who's met Tony lots of times. Brian put us together. And when I phone him, he seemed quite reluctant to talk at first. "Are you a Scientologist?" he asked me. He sounded a bit tongue-tied. "No." I said, equally tongue-tied. "Are you?" "No." he said. We both relaxed.
萨什达兰教授是一位独立的咨询精神病学家，他见过托尼很多次。布莱恩把我们牵线搭桥。当我给他打电话时，他起初显得很不情愿交谈。“你是科学教派成员吗？”他问我。他听起来有点结巴。“不，”我说，同样结巴。“你是吗？”“不是。”他说。我们都放松了下来。
Professor Sashidharan told tell me that, at one point, Tony was seen as one of the most dangerous men in Broadmoor. But Professor Sashidharan said he wasn't surprised that a young man would behave this way.
萨什达兰教授告诉我，在某个阶段，托尼被视为布罗德莫最危险的人之一。但萨什达兰教授说，他不惊讶一个年轻人会有这种行为。
In fact, the diagnosis of personality disorder should not be made in somebody who is as young as 16 or 17 because, you know, it's too early to say. Unfortunately, in Tony's case, the other reason why he attracted a diagnosis of personality disorder so quickly was that there was no longer any evidence of the mental illness doctors thought that he had once he came to Broadmoor. He was not getting treatment for any mental illness. The original symptoms, that the doctors thought they had identified when he was in prison, had all melted away. So they could no longer argue that he had a mental illness, therefore, he should be in hospital. So personality disorder diagnosis is quickly available to then justify his detention in a psychiatric hospital. And that's an honestly held view, it just happens to be the wrong view, in my opinion.
事实上，不应该对一个只有16或17岁的人做出人格障碍的诊断，因为，你知道，这下结论太早了。不幸的是，在托尼的案例中，他之所以这么快吸引到人格障碍诊断的另一个原因是，一旦来到布罗德莫，医生们此前认为他患有的精神病已不再有任何证据。他没有因任何精神病接受治疗。医生们在他入狱时认为已经确定的原始症状都烟消云散了。所以他们不能再辩称他患有精神病，因此他应该留在医院。所以人格障碍的诊断很快就被拿来正当化他在精神病院的拘留。而且这是一个真诚持有的观点，在我看来，这恰好是错误的观点。
Would you have a message for somebody who's just committed some grievous bodily harm and they're thinking, maybe I should fake mental illness because I bet it'll be more cushy in a hospital than in a prison. What would you recommend they do?
对于那些刚刚犯下严重身体伤害罪，并且心想“也许我应该伪装成精神病，因为我打赌医院肯定比监狱更舒服”的人，你有什么建议吗？你会推荐他们怎么做？
Unfortunately, it's a far too common occurrence for young people to claim-- well, not just young people, many people-- in my experience with speaking with these individuals, without exception, all of them will regret it, getting into a psychiatric hospital, because it's very easy to get into these places, but much, much more difficult to get out of those places.
不幸的是，年轻人声称患病——嗯，不仅仅是年轻人，许多人——这种现象太普遍了，根据我与这些个人的交谈经验，无一例外，他们所有人都会后悔进了精神病院，因为进这些地方很容易，但要出去却难得多、多得多。
Brian and I visit Tony one more time. Brian says he has a question he wants to ask him. Tony's not wearing the pinstripe this time, but he's still dressed a lot better than the other patients. He sits down. Brian leans forward. "Do you feel remorse?" he asks Tony. "My remorse," Tony immediately replies, "is that I've not just screwed up my victim's life, but also my own life, and my family's life. And that's my remorse. All the things that could have been done in my life, I feel bad about that every day."
布莱恩和我又去看了托尼一次。布莱恩说他有一个问题想问他。托尼这次没有穿那身条纹西装，但他穿得仍然比其他病人好得多。他坐了下来。布莱恩前倾身体。“你感到后悔吗？”他问托尼。“我的悔意，”托尼立刻回答，“是我不仅搞砸了受害者的生活，也搞砸了我自己的生活，还有我家人的生活。这就是我的悔意。所有那些在我生活中本可以完成的事情，我每天都为之感到难过。”
At this moment, Tony does sound to me like a man with remorse. And I decide, on the spot, that I will not talk to any more psychiatrists because I don't want them changing my mind about him again.
在这一刻，托尼听起来确实像一个有悔意的人。我当场决定，我不会再与任何精神病学家交谈，因为我不想让他们再次改变我对他的看法。
Brian says Tony's story demonstrates that no two psychiatrists can agree on anything, and they, basically, just make it up as they go along. I think his story demonstrates that it's a huge mistake to screw with psychiatrists. And you should be careful not to tell people you're crazy because you might turn out to be way too convincing about it.
布莱恩说托尼的故事表明没有任何两个精神病学家能在任何事情上达成一致，他们基本上就是边做边编。我认为他的故事表明，与精神病学家作对是一个巨大的错误。你应该小心不要告诉别人你疯了，因为你可能会变得太有说服力了。
Tony's life might be about to get better. Professor Maden emailed to say Tony's been in Broadmoor far too long for a crime that was not the most serious. And he's hoping to move him down to a nicer, medium-security unit. And then, maybe, even a community placement. I thought Tony would be happy about this, but when I ask him, he says he'll believe it when he sees it, and they've been talking about this kind of thing for years. And then a guard calls time. And with barely a goodbye, Tony obediently rushes across the Wellness Center and is gone.
托尼的生活可能会变得更好。马登教授发邮件说，托尼为了一个并非最严重的罪行在布罗德莫待得太久了。他希望把他调到一个更好的中级安全单位。然后，也许甚至可以安置到社区。我以为托尼会为此感到高兴，但当我问他时，他说他要等到亲眼看到才会相信，他们谈论这种事已经好几年了。然后一名警卫喊了时间。几乎没有告别，托尼顺从地跑过健康中心，消失了。
Jon Ronson, he's putting together this story and others into a new book that'll probably be called The Psychopath Test . Another of his books, The Men Who Stare at Goats , is about to be released as a movie starring George Clooney.
乔恩·荣森正在把这个故事和其他故事整理成一本新书，书名很可能叫《精神变态测试》。他的另一本书《以眼凝羊》即将被改编成由乔治·克鲁尼主演的电影。
Act 2, Disorder In The Court. So there are tons of non-lawyers representing themselves in court, everywhere. But the one area where nearly everybody uses a lawyer is criminal cases. So it's rare for a non-lawyer to defend himself in a criminal matter, and it's even more rare for him to win.
第二幕，“法庭混乱”。到处都有大量非律师人士在法庭上为自己辩护。但几乎每个人都使用律师的一个领域是刑事案件。所以非律师人士在刑事案件中为自己辩护是很罕见的，而能胜诉就更罕见了。
Well, back in April, a man named Jorge Cruz went into court on a drug charge: possession with intent to distribute. He admitted to the jury that he was a heroin addict. He fumbled around. He swore in court, and he won. He was up against an experienced and capable prosecutor who has won over 500 cases in the last five years, an Assistant District Attorney in Albany, New York named Francisco Calderon.
好吧，回溯到四月份，一个名叫豪尔赫·克鲁兹的人因毒品指控出庭：非法持有意图贩卖。他向陪审团承认他是一名海洛因成瘾者。他笨手笨脚。他在法庭上爆粗口，但他赢了。他的对手是一位经验丰富且能干的检察官，在过去五年中赢了超过500场官司，他就是纽约州奥尔巴尼的助理地方检察官弗朗西斯科·卡尔德隆。
When we called Calderon to invite him onto the radio show to talk about the case, he laughed and asked why couldn't we have him speak about one of the many cases that he's actually won? But he was game to come on the air and discuss what happened in this case. We weren't able to reach Jorge Cruz. Francisco Calderon says, initially, he was pretty confident about winning this case.
当我们打电话邀请卡尔德隆上广播节目谈论这个案子时，他笑了，并问为什么不能谈谈他实际赢下的那许多案子中的一个？但他还是答应上节目讨论这个案子发生的事情。我们没能联系到豪尔赫·克鲁兹。弗朗西斯科·卡尔德隆说，起初，他对赢得这个案子相当有信心。
Initially, you would think that this is going to be a slam dunk, and it became a little more uncomfortable as we went along.
起初，你会认为这会是一场必胜的仗，但随着审判的进行，它变得有点不舒服了。
Now, let me ask you to review the evidence against Jorge Cruz. What'd you have?
现在，请允许我回顾一下针对豪尔赫·克鲁兹的证据。你们有什么？
Certainly. Basically, the police had received a call for a woman being held against her will. Upon arriving at that address, they found the woman, who was there voluntarily. But at same time, they encountered two men that were there with her, Juan Cruz and a Jorge Cruz.
当然。基本上，警方接到一个电话，说一名妇女违背其意愿被拘禁。在到达该地址时，他们找到了那名妇女，她是自愿待在那里的。但在同一时间，他们遇到了与她在一起的两名男子，胡安·克鲁兹和豪尔赫·克鲁兹。
Upon entering the room, they observed what they believed to be drug paraphernalia. At that point in time, they secured all the parties, went and applied for a search warrant, and then executed a search warrant on the hotel room. This is a Motel 6. Underneath one of the mattresses, they discovered in excess of four ounces of cocaine and a couple bags of heroin.
进入房间后，他们观察到了他们认为是吸毒用具的东西。在那一刻，他们控制了所有相关人员，申请了搜查令，然后对酒店房间执行了搜查令。这是一个六号汽车旅馆。在其中一张床垫下，他们发现了超过四盎司的可卡因和几袋海洛因。
What was the street value of the drugs?
毒品的街头价值是多少？
Wholesale, you're talking about maybe $5,000. If you broke it down to individual doses, you could go easily up to $10,000 to $15,000.
批发价可能在5000美元左右。如果分拆成单次剂量，很容易达到10000到15000美元。
When this went to court, early in the case, Juan Cruz-- who is Jorge's brother, by the way-- and the woman from the hotel room, both, pled guilty. And that left Jorge Cruz, who declared that he would be defending himself, which suddenly made it a harder case for the prosecutor. When it was all three of them together, the prosecutor could argue that all three of them possessed the drugs together and convict them that way. But now Jorge Cruz could get up and say it was the other two, it wasn't him.
当这个案子进入法庭时，案子初期，顺便说一下，豪尔赫的兄弟胡安·克鲁兹和酒店房间里的那个女人都认罪了。这留下了豪尔赫·克鲁兹，他宣布将为自己辩护，这突然让检察官的案子变得更难处理。当他们三人在一起时，检察官可以辩称他们三人共同持有毒品并以此将他们定罪。但现在豪尔赫·克鲁兹可以站出来说那是另外两人的，不是他的。
His defense was that listen, I'm a user. I could never afford that amount of cocaine. I was just there to party, and not for the cocaine, but for the heroine. And so, basically, it was more of a sympathy, feel sorry for me, type of approach: that he had no money, he had no transportation, so he could never have possessed that amount of cocaine. He was going to spend time with his grandkids that morning. And I'm not a lawyer, I'm just here because I want to tell you my story.
他的辩护是，听着，我是一个吸食者。我根本买不起那么大数量的可卡因。我只是去那里聚会，不是为了可卡因，而是为了海洛因。所以，基本上，这更像是一种同情，“可怜可怜我”的方法：他没钱，没交通工具，所以他绝不可能持有那么大量的可卡因。他那天早上还要去陪他的孙子们。而且我不是律师，我来这里只是因为我想告诉你们我的故事。
Now he cursed while he was serving as his own lawyer?
那么他在担任自己的律师时爆了粗口？
Sure. I mean, there were times where the police had tried to link different pieces of evidence to him, and his attitude was like, that's bull [BLEEP]. Oh, excuse me. Sorry about that.
当然。我的意思是，有几次警方试图将不同的证据与他联系起来，他的态度就像是，那是胡扯（哔——）。哦，对不起。很抱歉。
We can beep that out.
我们可以把那个消音。
[LAUGHS] Sorry about that. Holy cow.
[笑] 抱歉。天哪。
I've read that, in cases like this, the pro se lawyer often turns to the prosecution for guidance. And I wondered if there was any point where he turned to you for guidance, or where you found yourself coaching him on the right way to do something?
我读到过，在像这样的案件中，自辩律师经常向控方寻求指导。我好奇是否有哪一点他向你寻求指导，或者你发现自己在指导他做某事的正确方法？
No. Not at all. In this particular case, the judge had an attorney sit with him.
没有。一点也没有。在这个特定的案子中，法官让一名律师坐在他身边。
And did that person actually give him a lot of advice?
那个人真的给了他很多建议吗？
I don't know if he gave him a lot of advice. He gave some pointers as to what to do at different points in time of the trial. But I believe that Jorge Cruz had in his mind what his defense was going to be and, basically, he just flopped around. And my goal was to try to keep him intact, as much as possible, within the bounds of the law.
我不知道他是否给了很多建议。他在审判的不同阶段给了他一些关于该做什么的提示。但我相信豪尔赫·克鲁兹心里已经有了他的辩护方案，基本上，他只是乱成一团。而我的目标是尽量让他保持在法律范围内，尽可能完整地进行。
What do you mean it was your goal to keep him intact? Explain that.
你说的“目标是让他保持完整”是什么意思？解释一下。
Well, there's certain things you can and cannot do in the courtroom. If a person is representing themselves, they're not going to abide by the rules of evidence. And my goal was to try to make sure that he didn't say things that would prejudice the case.
好吧，在法庭上有些事情你能做，有些不能。如果一个人代表自己，他们就不会遵守证据规则。我的目标是确保他不发表会损害案子的言论。
What were some of the things that he started to say that were improper that you had to stop him on?
他开始说的哪些不当言论是你必须制止他的？
Well, he would ask, like, one of the co-defendant witnesses, "Do you think I'm guilty?" or "You knew that I wasn't using drugs." So you can't phrase questions that way or talk to the guilt or innocence of his standing. When it's time for you to tell your portion of the story, it's when you're actually testifying, not when other witnesses are testifying, which he did throughout the whole trial, basically.
嗯，他会问，比如，其中一位共同被告证人，“你觉得我有罪吗？”或者“你知道我没吸毒。”所以你不能那样提问，也不能谈论他处于有罪还是无罪的地位。当你该说出你那部分故事时，是你实际上在作证的时候，而不是其他证人作证的时候，而他在整个审判过程中基本上一直这样做。
So how many times did you have to say objection?
那么你必须说多少次“反对”？
Oh, easily 50 times. I mean, there's only so much that you can do without being the bully. Obviously I don't want to give the impression to the jury that I'm trying to push this guy around.
哦，随便50次。我的意思是，你不可能在不显得像个恶霸的情况下做更多了。显然，我不想让陪审团觉得我是在试图欺负这个家伙。
And this really gets to the heart of your problem in prosecuting the case. You don't want to seem like an ass cutting this guy off all the time, over and over, to the jury because that'll lose the jury's sympathy.
这真正触及了你起诉该案问题的核心。你不想在陪审团面前表现得像个一直不断打断这个家伙的蠢货，因为那样会失去陪审团的同情。
No question about it. And it's a fine line. I tried to explain to the jurors that I'm not trying to prevent Mr. Cruz from telling his story, but there's a way that you can tell it.
毫无疑问。这是一条微妙的界限。我试图向陪审团解释，我并不是试图阻止克鲁兹先生讲他的故事，但讲故事是有方法的。
Damn.
该死。
Like a prime example of one thing that stands out to me that he said was, "You know, I'm going to have to do 10 years in prison for this." That never comes out at a trial, the amount of time or exposure that someone may get for the commission of a crime.
就像他说的让我印象深刻的一个主要例子是，“你知道，我为此得坐10年牢。”这种话在审判中绝不该出现，关于某人犯罪可能面临的刑期或量刑额度。
Right. It's a separate part of a trial. First you determine guilt or innocence, and then you figure out the sentence.
对。这是审判的一个独立部分。首先你确定有罪或无罪，然后你才决定判决。
That is correct. But when a defendant, while testifying, blurts out that I could do 10 years for this crime, it has an effect upon a jury. You cannot un-ring a bell.
正确。但当一名被告在作证时脱口而出“我因为这个罪行要坐10年牢”时，它会对陪审团产生影响。这种铃声一旦响起就无法抹去。
Was there any particular moment where you just thought, oh man. Suddenly where you thought, I might not win this, this is going bad?
有没有哪一个特定时刻你觉得，噢，伙计。突然间你觉得，我可能赢不了了，情况变得糟糕了？
There was a moment, and it wasn't until after closing arguments that-- I wasn't sure if I had connected with the jury in the manner that I was used to connecting with them. And as soon as I sat down and the judge began to give his instructions, I felt it. There's a feeling, and it's very difficult to put in words and explain.
有一个时刻，是在结案陈词之后——我不确定我是否以我习惯的方式与陪审团建立了联系。当我一坐下，法官开始给出指示时，我感觉到了。有一种感觉，很难用语言来解释。
No. No. I understand. You feel like you have their attention. You can tell they're with you.
不，不。我理解。你觉得你引起了他们的注意。你能看出他们站在你这一边。
No question about it. And there is something, there is a connection that you're able to form. Whereas, in this particular case, I felt that there was a lack of connection with the jury that I've had in the past.
毫无疑问。有一种东西，有一种你能够形成的联系。然而在这个特定的案子中，我觉得与陪审团缺乏我过去那种联系。
Do you think if Cruz had a lawyer, it would have been easier to convict him?
你觉得如果克鲁兹有律师，定罪会更容易吗？
Absolutely. Absolutely, because I don't think there would have been that stigma of the DA pushing and pushing. When you have an opposing counsel, it's expected that there is going to be give and take.
绝对会。绝对的，因为我不认为会有那种地区检察官咄咄逼人的污点。当你有一位对方律师时，人们预期会有来有往。
Right. If you're up against another lawyer, it's like watching two boxers box each other.
对。如果你面对的是另一位律师，那就像看两个拳击手对垒。
And, like I indicated, there's expected to be give and take. And in this instance, there really was not, and there's nothing sympathetic about what I'm doing here.
而且，正如我所指出的，人们预期会有来有往。而在这种情况下，确实没有，而且我在这里做的事情没有任何令人同情的成分。
Did you know what the court-appointed attorney was going to do as his defense? Did he talk to you about it afterwards?
你知道法院指定的律师打算怎么辩护吗？事后他和你聊过吗？
I'm sure it would have been along the same lines, they just would not have taken the same approach. I think he would have been a little more cautious in trying to limit Mr. Cruz from testifying, I think.
我肯定会是同样的路线，他们只是不会采取同样的方法。我想他会更谨慎地限制克鲁兹先生作证，我想。
Wait. You're saying that a professional defense attorney would have not wanted him to talk too much because he wouldn't have wanted him to seem like a big drug addict or something?
等等。你是说一位专业的辩护律师会不让他说太多，因为他不想让他显得像个大毒瘾者什么的？
Correct.
正确。
And that turned out to be the thing that probably won him the case.
而那恰好成了让他赢得这个案子的原因。
Well, again, had it been with an attorney representing him and he took the stand, he would not have been able to testify throughout the trial as he did.
嗯，再说一次，如果他有律师代表，而他上了证人席，他就不可能像他那样在整个审判过程中作证。
Well, in a way, he won exactly the only way that he could win. He won based on a personal appeal, by just winning people over with his personal story.
嗯，从某种程度上说，他赢的方式确实是他唯一能赢的方式。他是基于个人诉求赢的，仅仅是通过他个人的故事赢得了人们的支持。
Yeah, but that's the part that's so troubling here, because I don't view him as a person that would win someone over. So that's a troubling part of this whole case in that he didn't have that warm personality that could make a juror want to gravitate towards him. And maybe some of the jurors could maybe relate to him, but that's the most difficult part of this case for me in that I didn't find him to be a sympathetic figure. I just still haven't fully grasped that.
是的，但这部分在这里非常令人不安，因为我不认为他是一个会赢得别人支持的人。所以整个案子的这一部分很令人不安，因为他没有那种让陪审员想要被他吸引的温暖个性。也许有些陪审员能对他产生共鸣，但这对我来说是这个案子最困难的部分，因为我没觉得他是一个令人同情的角色。我至今还没完全理解这一点。
Was it galling to you that you could be beaten by an amateur?
输给一个业余人士对你来说感到丢脸吗？
Well, certainly. I mean, I have a great deal of pride in what I do, so to say that I wasn't a little miffed at it or unhappy would be an understatement. Certainly, I was not very happy about it, and to this day I'm not happy about it.
嗯，当然。我的意思是，我对自己所做的工作有很大的自豪感，所以说我不感到有点不爽或不高兴简直是轻描淡写。当然，我对此很不高兴，直到今天我对此也不高兴。
Francisco Calderon is an Assistant District Attorney in Albany, New York.
弗朗西斯科·卡尔德隆是纽约州奥尔巴尼的助理地方检察官。
Coming up, a student teacher decides to forgo all the rules and administer frontier justice that he invents on the fly. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，一位实习教师决定摒弃所有规则，实施他临时发明的边疆正义。稍后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际，节目继续。
This is This American Life from Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we feature a theme. We bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, pro se: stories of people representing themselves in all kinds of troubles in court and out of court.
这是艾拉·格拉斯带来的《美国生活》。每周我们的节目都有一个主题。我们带来关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目，“代表自己”：关于人们在法庭内外应对各种麻烦的故事。
We've arrived at Act 3 of our program. Act 3, Swak Down. This is a story recorded on stage by Jeff Simmermon at the storytelling series The Moth. We're going to hear the story, and then Jeff Simmermon's going to come into the studio with me. A warning to listeners: there's nothing dirty or anything in the story, but some of the content might not be right for little kids.
我们来到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，“吻我”。这是一个杰夫·西默蒙在讲故事系列《飞蛾》中在舞台上录制的故事。我们将听这个故事，然后杰夫·西默蒙会和我一起进入录音室。提醒听众：故事中没有什么脏东西或什么，但部分内容可能不适合小孩子。
So it's some time in college, and I'm going through that first big break-up that everybody goes through, that sort of marks their transition into adulthood. And I'm just sitting there on my bed. And I've got my face in my hands and I'm listening to The Smiths over and over again and just torturing myself and just going, "ooooh."
那是在大学期间的某个时候，我正在经历每个人都会经历的第一次大分手，这标志着他们向成年人的转变。我正坐在床上。我双手掩面，一遍又一遍地听着史密斯乐队的歌，折磨自己，一直在说，“噢”。
And my little sister comes into my room and sits down on the bed next to me. And she just gives me this huge hug. She puts her arms around me, and she takes a Kleenex out, and dabs my tears, and said, "Jeff, listen. Bitches gonna come and bitches gonna go. But you've been there for me since the day I was born, and that kind of love, that's forever. I'm gonna love you till after you are dead, and I am not lying."
我的小妹妹走进我的房间，坐在我旁边的床上。她给了我一个大大的拥抱。她用手臂搂住我，拿出一张纸巾，擦干我的眼泪，说：“杰夫，听着。婊子会来，婊子会走。但从我出生的那天起你就一直在我身边，那种爱，是永恒的。我会爱你直到你死后，我没撒谎。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
For real.
真的。
[APPLAUSE AND LAUGHTER]
[掌声和笑声]
And then, she continues and says, "And I just wanted you to know that I have always hated that bitch. And if you want, I'll be happy, more than happy, to go around to her crib and whip her ass with a dog chain one time. You just say the word." I just took the hug.
然后，她继续说，“我只是想让你知道，我一直很讨厌那个婊子。如果你想，我很乐意，非常乐意去她的住处，用狗链狠狠抽她一顿。你只要说一声。”我就接受了这个拥抱。
What you need to understand is that we have the same parents. We grew up in the same home. She was in the 9th grade. Because while I was off at college studying art and listening to Sonic Youth, she and her friends were on another track. And she was invited to join a gang, but we've never been into group things, she just freelanced. And she and her friends used to break into rich people's houses. And they would drink 40s, and take pictures of it, and leave the 40s and whatever, and just leave.
你需要了解的是，我们有相同的父母。我们在同一个家里长大。她读九年级。因为当我在大学学习艺术并听着音速青年乐队时，她和她的朋友们走在另一条路上。她曾被邀请加入一个帮派，但我们从不参与团体活动，她只是单干。她和她的朋友们过去常闯入有钱人的房子。他们会喝40盎司装的啤酒，拍照，留下空瓶子什么的，然后直接走人。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And her boyfriend at the time, his winter coat and his mustache had this inversely proportional size relationship where his coat, sort of, advertised a faraway hockey team and he had this nasty little weasel penis draped across his top lip. And just something in his eyes was that dangerous combination of weak and predatory.
当时的男朋友，他的冬装外套和他的胡子有种反比例关系，他的外套广告着一个遥远的冰球队，而他的上唇上留着那种令人讨厌的黄鼠狼胡子。他眼睛里的某种东西是软弱和掠夺性的危险组合。
And so I was working as an art teacher at her high school as a practicum thing in order to graduate. And I'm walking down the hall one day, and I hear the laughter that I was very accustomed to hearing from back when I was in high school. And I see her boyfriend and some of his similarly parka'd friends shoving somebody into a locker. And they're just shoving him, and laughing, and shoving him, and laughing. And I get up to them, and I'm just kind of sheep-dogging kids off to class. And I'm like, what is this bull [BLEEP]. Go on! Go to class! Go! Go! Go! And I look, and the kid that they're shoving up against the locker is my little sister.
所以我当时在她的高中做艺术老师，作为毕业前的实习。有一天，我走在走廊里，听到了我上高中时非常熟悉的笑声。我看到她的男朋友和一些同样穿着帕克大衣的朋友把某人塞进储物柜。他们一直在推他，大笑，再推他，再大笑。我走过去，像牧羊犬一样把孩子们赶去上课。我说，这是什么胡扯。走开！去上课！快！快！快！我一看，被他们推向储物柜的孩子是我的小妹妹。
And she has that look on her face, that I know so well, where her jaw is really set and her eyes are huge and wet. And she is definitely not crying. She is fine. And having been responsible for that look in the past, I know what it takes to provoke that. And I was like, are you OK? Are you OK? Do you need me to do something? And she's like, "I'm fine! [BLEEP] I gotta go! [BLEEP]!" and then just leaves.
她脸上有着我非常熟悉的表情，下巴紧绷，眼睛又大又湿。她绝对没有哭。她没事。曾经导致那种表情的我，知道需要什么才能激怒她。我说，你没事吧？你没事吧？需要我做什么吗？她说，“我没事！[哔——]我得走了！[哔——]！”然后就离开了。
And I just, instantly, burn with a white-hot rage. And I have all sorts of elaborate and horrific revenge fantasies that involve roping the dude to the back of my bumper and dragging him up and down the highway. Or covering him with gas and setting him on fire, whatever.
然后我立刻燃起了炽热的愤怒。我有各种各样精致而可怕的复仇幻想，包括把那家伙绑在我的保险杠后面，沿着高速公路把他拖来拖去。或者给他浇上汽油并点火，随便什么。
And it's very difficult to teach that day. And I don't know what to do, but this aggression will not stand, man. I gotta do something. And then I'm coming back from my planning bell, and I'm coming up the stairs, and I see him standing there on the stairwell. And the window is open, and he's looking out the window. And he's got this dopey little smile on his open mouth. And the breeze is playfully ruffling his mullet off of his shoulders.
那天很难教书。我不知道该怎么办，但这股侵略性不会就这样结束，伙计。我得做点什么。然后我在计划课后回来，走上楼梯，看到他站在楼梯间。窗户开着，他正看着窗外。他张开的嘴上带着傻乎乎的小笑容。微风顽皮地吹乱了他肩膀上的鲻鱼头。
And I get up to him, and I just drop my hand on his shoulder, and I spin him around and I say, "Hey, man! I saw you in the hall with my sister." And then I run out of plan.
我走到他面前，把手放在他的肩膀上，让他转过身来说，“嘿，伙计！我在走廊里看到你和我妹妹在一起了。”然后我就没词了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Because I've been spending all day daydreaming about all this awesome, cinematic stuff I want to do and not really figuring out what would happen if I actually got to confront him, which is weird since we're in the same building all day. And I can't think of anything. I'm just pulling him in closer. And I look him in the eye, I was like, "I saw you in the hall with my sister." And I want to bite his lips off and just spit them on the floor. And I can't exactly do that, so I just give him a big, long kiss right on the mouth. And I keep my eyes open, and I lock eyes with him. And I can feel his mustache against my back lip. And the whole time I'm thinking, dominate and intimidate.
因为我整天都在幻想我想做的那些酷炫的电影般的事情，并没有真正考虑到如果我真的面对他会发生什么，这很奇怪，因为我们整天在同一栋楼里。我想不出什么。我只是把他拉近一点。我直视他的眼睛，我说，“我在走廊里看到你和我妹妹在一起了。”我真想咬掉他的嘴唇，直接吐在地上。我做不到，所以我只是在他的嘴上重重地吻了一口。我睁着眼睛，与他对视。我能感觉到他的胡子擦着我的后唇。整个过程中我一直在想，支配和恐吓。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And I pushed him back. And I was like, "Um, look, it's cool." I can't think of anything to say. And I was just like, "You can come over whenever you want. I look forward to seeing you around. Goodbye."
然后我推开他。我说，“嗯，看，这很酷。”我想不出什么可说的。我就像，“你可以随时过来。我期待着见到你。再见。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And split. And I just kind of go home. And later that night, my sister came home. And they had met up after school and had a big fight. And they'd broken up. But she looked at me, she said, "Mother [BLEEP], are you out of your rabid-ass mind? What were you even thinking?" And I said, "Jess, bitches gonna come and bitches gonna go, but you have been there for me since the day you were born. And that kind of love, that is real, and it is lifelong. And I'm gonna love you till after you are dead. And I am not even lying, for real."
然后闪人。我只是回了家。那天晚上晚些时候，我妹妹回家了。他们放学后见了面，打了一大架。他们分手了。但她看着我说，“妈的，你的脑子是让狗吃了吗？你到底在想什么？”我说，“杰西，婊子会来，婊子会走，但从你出生的那天起你就一直在我身边。那种爱，是真实的，是终身的。我会爱你直到你死后。我真的没撒谎。”
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
[笑声和掌声]
So Jeff, for a minute, joins me in the studio. Jeff, your story raises some important questions, and I want to go through those with you right now. First of all, why the kiss?
杰夫，有一分钟加入我的演播室。杰夫，你的故事引发了一些重要的问题，我想现在和你谈谈。首先，为什么亲他？
It was all that I could think of at the time. I was very limited in what I could do, you know? Had I pursued violence-- this is the kind of guy, he rolled around with a crew. Drive-bys happened in my hometown a lot. And had I beaten him up like I wanted to-- I don't really know how to beat people up-- he could have come back later with some sort of drive-by scenario. Or he could have taken his bruises, or whatever, to the administration, I could never teach again. So I had to do something that was completely off the map.
那是当时我唯一能想到的。我的选择非常有限，你知道吗？如果我追求暴力——他是那种带着帮派的人。在我家乡经常发生免下车枪击案。如果我像我想的那样打他一顿——我真的不知道怎么打人——他可能后来带着某种枪击场景回来。或者他可能带着伤，什么的，向行政部门举报，我就永远不能再教书了。所以我必须做一些完全出格的事情。
Could we talk about the moment after you kiss him?
我们可以谈谈你吻他之后的那一刻吗？
Sure.
当然。
Were you just as surprised as he was?
你当时和他一样惊讶吗？
Yes. Possibly more so.
是的。可能更甚。
Did you know you had this in you?
你知道你体内有这一面吗？
No.
不知道。
And how did you feel after you did it? Did you feel like, yes, score?
你做完之后感觉如何？你觉得，耶，得分了？
No. I felt terrified. I felt that I am past the point of no return right now. And whatever happens, there's no counsel for me.
没有。我觉得很害怕。我觉得我现在已经过了无法回头的点了。无论发生什么，我都没有后路。
If you had to summarize in a sentence your message to him with that kiss, like why you chose the kiss, what would you say?
如果你要用一句话总结你那个吻传递给他的信息，就像你为什么选择吻他，你会怎么说？
You've opened the lid on forces that nobody knows how to deal with. Close the box and step away.
你已经打开了没人知道怎么处理的力量的盖子。关上盒子，退后。
So with this kid, you decide you're going to take the law into your own hands. You're going to be the one to fix this. You're going to set this right. What if you had tried to protect her in a more traditional way? You know, go to one of the other teachers, or the principal, and just get him suspended or expelled or something?
所以在这个孩子身上，你决定你要把法律掌握在自己手中。你要成为解决这件事的人。你要纠正这件事。如果你尝试用更传统的方式保护她呢？你知道，去找其他老师或者校长，让他被停课或开除什么的？
Because it wouldn't have worked. He wouldn't have cared. He didn't come to school enough for a suspension to be a meaningful change in his life one way or the other. I think he wouldn't have gotten the message. I don't think he would've gotten it. I think life would have continued unabated. He may have continued dating my sister, or may have continued shoving her around. Nothing would have stopped. Nothing would have changed. There had to be change.
因为那不会起作用。他不会在乎。他没去学校上课，停课对他来说不会是生活中的任何重大改变。我想他不会收到信息的。我认为他不会明白。我想生活会继续下去，不受影响。他可能继续和我妹妹约会，或者继续推推搡搡她。什么都不会停止。什么都不会改变。必须有所改变。
Jeff Simmermon, he does other stories on his blog, andiamnotlying.com. That's and I am not lying, all one word. Thanks, as always, to The Moth, which uses personal stories told live in front of an audience. For more Moth stories, check out the Moth's great, free, weekly podcast at themoth.org. And The Moth is starting its own radio show, The Moth Radio Hour, which will be coming to many public radio stations this August.
杰夫·西默蒙，他在他的博客 andiamnotlying.com 上写其他故事。一如既往地感谢《飞蛾》，它使用在观众面前现场讲述的个人故事。想听更多《飞蛾》故事，查看《飞蛾》免费、精彩的每周播客 themoth.org。《飞蛾》正在开启自己的广播节目，《飞蛾电台一小时》，今年八月将在许多公共广播电台播出。
Act 4, Underling Gets An Underling. This is the story of somebody in a job that sounds like the kind of thing that would be, sort of, exciting. Stef Willen worked on a bunch of reality TV shows, but she was a production assistant, a PA, which is the lowest rung on the ladder. She did a lot of emptying trash cans.
第四幕，“下属有了下属”。这是一个人的故事，他在一份听起来很令人兴奋的工作中工作。斯特夫·威伦在许多真人秀节目中工作，但她是一名制作助理（PA），这是梯队的最底层。她做了很多清空垃圾桶的工作。
I remember running around town with the weirdest lists of stuff to get, like toilet paper with a specific pattern on it. I've had one boss, she would do things like ask me to hang curtains in her office. And I was like, "Oh, but your wall is made of concrete." And she was like, "Oh, you can do it." You know? Stuff like that. I would be given these bizarre tasks, and if you didn't do them right, there was always this sense of are you stupid?
我记得在城里跑来跑去拿最奇怪的东西清单，比如特定图案的卫生纸。我有一个老板，她会做一些事情，比如让我去她的办公室挂窗帘。我说，“哦，但你的墙是混凝土做的。”她说，“哦，你能做到的。”你知道？诸如此类的事情。我会接到这些奇怪的任务，如果你没做对，总有一种“你是不是蠢”的感觉。
And so the way understand it is that towards the end you came up with a plan. Can I ask you to just describe the plan that you came up with?
所以我理解的是，临近最后你提出了一个计划。我可以请你描述一下你提出的那个计划吗？
I just thought it would be hilarious if I came in the next day with an eager young person who was my production assistant.
我只是觉得如果我第二天带一个渴望学习的年轻人，作为我的制作助理，那会很搞笑。
Oh. So you would be a PA and you would have your own PA.
哦。所以你成了制作助理，然后你有你自己的制作助理。
Exactly. Which is really unnecessary. It's a gopher with a gopher, so I don't know. I wanted to make a point. It'd just be like a little sweet revenge, you know?
完全正确。这真的很没必要。这是一个跑腿的人带着另一个跑腿的人，所以我不知道。我想表达一个观点。那就像是一点甜蜜的复仇，你知道吗？
Right.
对。
I don't know.
我不知道。
No. No. I understand. You'd be upsetting the natural order.
不。不。我理解。你正在打破自然秩序。
Right. Totally. It's like, if you can get someone under you, it's simple math, but you are not at the bottom. I just knew that I was somehow taking control over what was happening in my life if I could put someone just right under me.
对。完全正确。这就像，如果你能把你下面的人搞定，这就是简单的数学，但你不再是底层了。我只是知道，如果我能把我下面的人搞定，我就以某种方式掌控了生活中发生的事情。
So, OK. So you're a PA hiring a PA. How'd you go about it?
所以，好了。所以你是一名制作助理雇佣了一名制作助理。你是怎么做的？
I wrote up a Craigslist seeking a production assistant on a popular reality TV show. For the ability, I said must possess a medium work ethic, the ability to take out trash, and then sit for hours and work for free. And 21 people responded. 21 people. I was amazed.
我在 Craigslist 上写了一个招聘，招聘一个热门真人秀节目的制作助理。关于能力，我说必须具备中等的工作道德，有能力倒垃圾，然后坐上几个小时免费工作。21个人回复了。21个人。我惊呆了。
I ended up going with this guy, I'll call him Adam. It was interesting, I hired him because I actually felt like he might be slightly delinquent. When we had our, quote, unquote, "interview," he never turned down his car radio. And it was that kind of thing. And I'm like, OK. Well, we're going to meet at the coffee shop and we're going to drive to set. "OK." I'm like, "Do you want to get out a pen and a paper and write this down?" "Oh, OK."
我最终选择了这个家伙，我叫他亚当。很有趣，我雇佣他是因为我确实觉得他可能稍微有点问题少年。当我们面试的时候，他从来没关过车里的收音机。就是那种事。我说，好吧。我们要在一个咖啡店见面，然后我们要开车去片场。“好的。”我说，“你要拿一支笔和纸记下来吗？”“哦，好的。”
Oh, wow. So he's really a real beginner. Like, he really was not necessarily ready for the responsibility of a--
哦，哇。所以他真的是个新手。他并不一定准备好承担……的责任。
Of a phone conversation.
电话通话的责任。
Yeah. Or a job.
是的。或者工作。
Yeah. I met him at a coffee shop. And he was this nice looking young guy. And he was wearing this argyle sweater and this scarf and a beret. And I was like, "Oh, my gosh. What did I just do?"
是的。我在咖啡店见了他。他是一个好看的年轻人。他穿着这件菱形针织衫，围着围巾，戴着贝雷帽。我说，“天哪。我刚做了什么？”
A beret?
贝雷帽？
A beret. Yeah. He followed me in his car to set, and I was getting a little nervous because I actually hadn't planned anything past this point. The first person we see is the line producer, and she was frantic, as always. You know, "Come on. Come on. We've got a big day. We've got to get going." And I said, "Oh, well you'll be glad to know I have some help. This is Adam, and he is my production assistant for today." And she just sort of stopped and looked at me. And she goes, "Well, good. We need the extra help." And there was no Stef is a genius. Or, oh look what Steff did. It was, literally, like oh, thank you. Oh, we need the help. How did you get him to work for free?
贝雷帽。是的。他开车跟着我去片场，我开始有点紧张，因为我确实没计划这一步之后的事情。我们见到的第一个人是制片经理，她一如既往地疯狂。你知道，“快点。快点。我们有重要的一天。我们得出发了。”我说，“哦，好吧，你会很高兴知道我有一些帮手。这是亚当，他是今天我的制作助理。”她停下看我。她说，“好吧，很好。我们需要额外的帮助。”没有那种“斯特夫是个天才”或者“哦，看斯特夫做了什么”。它是，真的，就像“哦，谢谢。哦，我们需要帮助。”你是怎么让他免费工作的？
And so you did introduce him to your bosses?
所以你把他介绍给了你的老板？
Yeah. I introduced him to everybody. I mean, I don't know why I thought that they would learn something from it, but I totally underestimated I guess, the joke, but also their need for workers. They were in production mode. They're not stopping to look at what I'm trying to say. They're like, OK. Well, we're 10 minutes behind. We can use Adam over here in hair and makeup.
是的。我把他介绍给了所有人。我的意思是，我不知道为什么我觉得他们会从中学到什么，但我完全低估了这个笑话，也低估了他们对工人的需要。他们处于制作模式。他们不停下来看我想说什么。他们说，好的。好吧，我们落后了10分钟。我们可以用亚当在发型和化妆那边。
So you were hoping that they would get the lesson of, you see, this whole system you have is so arbitrary? And, we're not just cogs in a machine. Like, I could be a boss. And the lesson they took was not only are you all cogs in a machine, but you're such a cog, we can't even see that you're talking. Like you're not even an animal making noise here. Like, OK. Now, hand me that other animal over there.
所以你希望他们学到，“你看，你们拥有的整个系统是如此武断”这门课？而且，我们不仅仅是机器里的齿轮。就像，我也能成为老板。而他们学到的教训不仅是你们都是机器里的齿轮，而且你们是如此齿轮，我们甚至看不出你在说话。就像你甚至不是一个会发出声音的动物。就像，好的。现在，把那边那只动物递给我。
Yeah. Exactly. It's like, oh, two cogs for one. Awesome. We'll take this one, you know? I went from his boss to his sidekick to, I don't know, his buddy? I'd be like, oh, I got this trash can. So it would be really gross and disgusting, and I'm like, oh, I don't want to mess up his scarf. I made sure he ate first. Like, he got his lunch before me.
是的。完全正确。这就像，哦，两个齿轮当一个用。太棒了。我们会用这个，你知道吗？我从他的老板变成了他的跟班，然后变成了，我不知道，他的伙伴？我会说，哦，我有这个垃圾桶。所以它会变得非常恶心和令人作呕，我想，哦，我不想弄脏他的围巾。我确保他先吃饭。就像，他比我先吃午饭。
At one point, we were all sitting around the table. We'd been sitting staring at each other for about two hours, because they were filming, with nothing to do. And I looked over at Adam, and he had taken his beret off and it was on his knee. And he was, sort of, slouched down, and he was moving M&M's across his plate, one by one, with his index finger. And I think he said, "I have never not done anything for this long a time." And I was like, "Well, you know, it did say in my ad the ability to sit for hours." And he laughed.
有一次，我们都坐在桌子旁。我们盯着对方看了大约两个小时，因为他们在拍摄，无事可做。我看向亚当，他摘下贝雷帽放在膝盖上。他有点颓废，他正用食指把M&M豆一个一个移到盘子里。我想他说，“我从来没有这么长时间什么都不做。”我说，“好吧，你知道，我的广告上确实写了具备坐几个小时的能力。”他笑了。
But shortly after, I told him to go. I was like, "Well, you know, you did a great job today. Definitely send me your resume." He kept in touch, like, he would email, do you know so-and-so? Or just little questions, you know? And then, at one point, he stopped asking me questions. And I got this text from him at 8:26 AM, and it said, "I want you." Period. "I want your body." Period. "Right now." Period. And I was like, OK.
但不久之后，我让他走了。我说，“好吧，你知道，你今天做得很好。一定要把简历发给我。”他保持联系，就像，他会发邮件，你认识某某某吗？或者只是小问题，你知道吗？然后，有一次，他停止问我问题了。我在早上8:26收到他的短信，他说，“我要你。”句号。“我要你的身体。”句号。“现在。”句号。我说，好吧。
What did that say to you?
那对你说了什么？
That he had not taken me seriously at all.
他根本没把我当回事。
So you got him into your life because nobody else took you seriously, and then even he doesn't take you seriously.
所以你把他带进你的生活是因为没人把你当回事，然后连他都不把你当回事。
Right. It just, sort of, made me laugh. I thought, OK. Well, he wants my body right now, which, 8:26 AM, that wasn't a good time for me.
对。它只是，让我笑了。我想，好吧。好吧，他现在想要我的身体，这，早上8:26，对我来说不是个好时间。
Stef Willen, she has quit her PA jobs. She starred in the independent film, M, which won last year's Seattle International Film Festival, and she's writing a book.
斯特夫·威伦，她已经辞去了制作助理的工作。她主演了独立电影《M》，该片赢得了去年的西雅图国际电影节奖项，她正在写一本书。
Well, the program was produced today by Sarah Koenig and myself with Alex Blumberg, Sean Cole, Jane Feltes, Lisa Pollak, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our Senior Producer is Julie Snyder. Our production help from Andy Dixon and Aaron Scott. Seth Lind is our Production Manager. Music help from Jessica Hopper. And this is our last show with our very precocious intern, Andi Dixon, who we all wish the best to, whether she ends up in grad school, or a job, or what's most likely, both.
嗯，今天的节目由萨拉·科尼格和我制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、肖恩·科尔、简·费尔特斯、丽莎·波拉克、阿莉莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。我们的制作帮助来自安迪·迪克森和亚伦·斯科特。塞思·林德是我们的制作经理。音乐帮助来自杰西卡·霍珀。这是我们与非常早熟的实习生安迪·迪克森的最后一期节目，我们祝愿她一切顺利，无论她是去读研究生、找工作，还是最可能的，两者兼顾。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。